president Trump's new lawyer says a
personal financial disclosure removes
any suspicion that the president broke
campaign finance law in connection with
stormy Daniels the document confirms the
president reimbursed attorney Michael
Cohen between one hundred and two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
Cohen paid the adult film star a hundred
and thirty thousand dollars to keep
silent about an alleged fare with mr.
Trump in 2006 the president denies
having sex with Daniels just last month
he said he knew nothing about the
payment Paula Reid is at the White House
with the admission that critics say
should have been revealed last year
Paula good morning good morning this
disclosure comes after weeks of
contradictory statements from the
President and his attorneys about that
payment to stormy Daniels while the
president's attorneys say they disclose
this in the interest of transparency the
office of government ethics says
actually it was required the president
disclosed everything he could disclose
president Trump's attorney Rudy Giuliani
told Fox News that he doesn't believe
the president's financial disclosures
are a liability we're very comfortable
with it and we think it indicates our
original strategy also indicates the
fact that Muller should now bring this
to a close
president Trump has previously denied
knowledge of the payment
but earlier this month Giuliani first
revealed to Fox News the president paid
Cohen back some stormy Daniels woman
130,000 I mean which is going to turn
out to be perfectly legal
Brendan Fischer works at the bipartisan
watchdog campaign Legal Center president
Trump's financial disclosure report is
effectively an admission that $130,000
in debt was omitted from last year's
report failing to report a debt on a
report like this is a violation of
federal law along with the financial
disclosures form the office of
government ethics sent a letter to
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen sign
flagging the update in case it was
relevant to any inquiry the Justice
Department may be pursuing the office of
government ethics says the letter should
not be seen as a criminal referral and
it was simply providing information to
the Justice Department but there are
still outstanding legal questions about
the Daniels payment it very much appears
that the payment was made for the
purpose of influencing the 2016 election
and with that com potential campaign
finance violations the Daniels payment
doesn't appear to have anything to do
with Russia so it's unlikely that any
investigation into that payment would
fold into the Muller probe despite
Giuliani's insistence on trying to link
the two
but both Mahler and the Justice
Department have said that they don't
believe they have the authority to
indict a sitting president what they do
have the authority to do though is refer
any evidence of criminal wrongdoing to
Congress for possible impeachment
proceedings
bianna financial statement just raises
more and more questions Paula thank you